hey 42 here do you know what's going on
in the earth beneath your feet the world
we know barely scratches the surface and
far below strange societies thrive in
the deepest and darkest of places these
are the tales of the modern day
societies that live below the earth's
surface buried under the streets of
regal paris lies a most macabre
underworld known as the catacombs this
dusty of Shoei holds the bones of over 6
million people secure within the
twisting array of tunnels and caves its
passages cover nearly three hundred and
twenty one kilometers of sprawling
subterranean real estate one wrong turn
and you might find yourself wandering
amongst the dead for eternity originally
the catacombs were a network of tunnels
dating back to the 13th century the
remnants of the limestone mines which
caused Paris to grow into the city we
know today by the 17th century the
burgeoning city had filled all of its
cemeteries to capacity flooding the
streets with the delightful aroma of
decaying flesh odor corpse anyone
towards the end of the 18th century the
situation continued to deteriorate King
Louis the 15th decided that enough was
enough and decreed that no more burials
will be allowed within the city limits
though due to resistance from the clergy
the cemeteries remained undisturbed it
wasn't until the reign of Louis the
fifteenth successor louis xvi
that the crusade against a body odor
made any progress louis xvi flexed his
royal muscle and declared that all
cemeteries were to be relocated outside
of the city but still the clergy refused
to budge in 1780 torrential rains
saturated the soil causing the bodies
contained in one cemetery to surface and
spill onto the adjacent land thankfully
after this unfortunate event the rest of
the city agreed that something must be
done it's all fun and games until
there's a body on your lawn by 1798 the
occupants of every cemetery in the city
had been moved by hand
from their former homes into their final
resting places within the catacombs a
job that certainly no one would envy the
catacombs saw used throughout the French
Revolution and in 1860 the government
finally decided they had filled the
tunnels sufficiently since then the
catacombs have been a haven for urban
explorers and others who wish to haunt
the gloom with the dead despite one of
the entrances to the catacombs bearing a
sign which reads stop this is the Empire
of death you can find many signs of life
down there today in 2004 the Parisian
police stumbled upon a bizarre complex
within the catacombs
complete with electrical power a cinema
a restaurant phone lines and a
closed-circuit surveillance system if
that isn't the lair of a super villain
that I don't know what is the place had
seemingly been abandoned by the time
police discovered it though there were
clear signs of recent occupation when
they returned three days later with city
infrastructure experts they found that
the phone lines and Power had been
caught and an ominous note was left for
them which read do not try to find us
only a very small section of the
catacombs are open to the public via a
guided tours only the other mass expanse
of sprawling tunnels are strictly
off-limits many explorers and boarding
residents however used secret entrances
to access the catacombs found in
peculiar places such as in the basements
of bars and in small gaps in the walls
of the Metro tunnels the locations of
these secret entrances are told to
others only in strict confidence to
avoid the authorities finding them and
sealing them permanently this secret
network of illegal catacomb adventurers
are known as cata files they have to be
secretive because accessing the non
tourist area of the catacombs is
strictly illegal and there's a hefty
fine if caught if you do plan on
plunging into the catacombs on an
exploration of your own be sure to use
the body system this is one place you do
not want to get lost because if you
your chances of ever finding your way
out are virtually non-existent
sequestered from the heat and the Sun of
the Mojave Desert the tunnel people of
Las Vegas carve out a living in the
miles of flood tunnels beneath the city
they live in a world of Perpetual
Twilight eternally wary of the dangerous
creatures indigenous to the region and
the looming threat of rain rushing in to
wash away their few possessions the
tunnels flood often and the tunnel
people call a flawed after a powerful
rainstorm flushing the toilet they have
to be ever vigilant ready to relocate at
a moment's notice and not exactly a
sedentary lifestyle Las Vegas has a
reputation as the gleaming gem of the
desert a beacon of civilization and
extravagance where what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas this also includes the
people who pulled up stakes and migrated
their entire lives in a moment to the
asphalt oasis only to discover that
making a living amongst the glittering
casinos and luxurious hotels wasn't as
easy as they thought or perhaps a
tragedy forced them out of a secure
lifestyle and onto the streets either
way these nomads usually find their way
to the foot tunnels to join the tunnel
people making a living doing whatever
odds-and-ends they can in the bustling
city above usually referred to as normal
people of all ages who've lost their way
their numbers include children men and
women struggling with addiction and even
war veterans coping with post-traumatic
stress disorder
despite their dire circumstances the
resilience of the human spirit is
evident in the culture they built for
themselves the tunnel walls are painted
with elaborate Rafi tea arts and pieces
of furniture designating rudimentary
rooms in the gloom motor tunnel people
live far beneath the public eye and the
glamour of the Vegas Strip they are not
forgotten the shine a light foundation
formed by a journalist in partnership
with the charity help of Southern Nevada
brings necessity
such as food and water to the tunnels
along with blankets and other assistance
bit by bits the partnership work to
improve the lives of the impoverished to
know people forming a flickering light
of hope in a very dark place like the
tunnel people of Las Vegas the
inhabitants of the Bucharest series in
Romania live in a dimly lit underworld
beneath the capital city they have
access to a few more amenities in their
American counterparts with electricity
powering white bulbs which dangle from
the ceilings in certain areas as well as
over electronic lawsuits however it's
not quite as cheery as it might see
hidden away from the denizens of the
capital above-ground the people of the
Bucharest sewers are true societal
castaways though the citizens of
Bucharest are aware of the growing
community beneath their feet few offer
any kind of assistance nearly all of the
members of the underworld test HIV
positive with a large portion also
suffering from tuberculosis
despite the meager amount of light
floating the hollows they call home
darkness lurks in every nook and cranny
the streets overhead can be a harsh
place to make a living the sewer is
becoming somewhat of a refuge as they
offer a modicum of safety and warmth and
yet the brutal reality of their life
continues to haunt land refugees within
the sheer concrete walls many of them
turning to drugs as a means of escape
one man who goes by the name of Bruce
Lee serves as a self-appointed vanguard
of the sewers he brings regular care
packages of various drugs and
distributes them to all in need of a
moment's respite though it would be easy
to consider him the villain of this
particular story he has also taken it
upon himself to protect the children
down there from others who would bring
them harm as well as paying local city
gangs to stand sentry over the sewers
and protect them from antagonists sadly
life has become a game of maintain the
status quo with little opportunity for
improvement aid organizations in Romania
rely on funds from overseas to continue
their operations
recently the monetary assistance has
ceased flowing into the country
rendering the relatively small aid
organizations impotent for the time
being life continues for Romania's
Bucharest sewer people as it has for
years fading into memory with a steady
stream of drugs as a coping mechanism
and with only the barest of survival
essentials boats as long as Bruce Lee
rules over his simple kingdom perhaps
they can take comfort in having some
small measure of security rather than
being driven underground by
circumstances the farmers of the lowest
plateau in Yunnan China choose to carve
dwelling caves from the earth out of
convenience instead evoke images of Luke
Skywalker's subterranean home and
Tatooine in the sci-fi spectacular Star
Wars the farmers take advantage of the
plateaus soft soil to dig traditional yo
donkeys for themselves and their
families
the yay of Dawg are seen as important
family heirlooms to be passed from
generation to generation many of them
are now so old that the exact number of
generations who have occupied them has
been lost to the mists of time even if
they can't tell you who lived there
centuries ago millions of people still
call the caves home to this day
archeologists have determined that the
people of the lowest plateau
first began digging homes during the
Zhou Dynasty between 1046 and 221 BC
over the years the cave dwellers came to
typify three varieties of yodon't those
dug into the cliffs others set down into
the soil and the last type being
structures built partially into or
against a mound of earth some of the
cave dwellings came to incorporate brick
and stone into their design and it's
these that proved to be the
longest-lasting some have been upgraded
with modern amenities and comforts but
no word on whether they have fiber optic
internet yet each family generally has
between three and five young with the
one at the center serving as the main
residence for the older members of the
family thanks to the insulative
properties of the earthen walls the
caves maintain a pleasant temperature
all year round
need for air conditioning or central
heating perhaps the yayo dong dwellers
are onto something the breathtaking
yellow terrain of the loess plateau and
many yay Oh dong dotting the countryside
have become a popular tourist attraction
in recent years if you fancy a simple
life of peace and plenty whilst living
in harmony with the earth Yan'an is one
of the last places on earth where you
could carve your own life from the very
ground beneath you with like-minded
folks of course you could try to dig a
cave dwelling elsewhere but you might
get some strange looks
in 1969 the Chinese people were
beginning to feel the heat from the Cold
War
Chairman Mao Zedong sensing the growing
potential for overt hostility decreed
that tunnels and air-raid bunkers were
to be built beneath major cities leading
to the construction of the area's now
occupied by the rapp tribe of beijing
though the underground shelters were
never meant for prolonged occupation
they have become home to millions of
citizens and migrant workers who simply
can't afford to live in the city above
the rat tribe have since claimed many of
the city's basements and other sub
levels for rudimentary residences and
hostels to house the growing throng in
need of cheap accommodation due to the
cramped conditions members of the rat
tribe often share bathrooms and kitchens
with thin walls separating them from
their neighbours not exactly the best
place to practice your karaoke I imagine
as a result of the construction projects
and infrastructure development brought
about by the 2008 Beijing Olympics
thousands of migrants were brought in to
perform the manual labor left with no
other options many of them flocked
through the underground where they were
distinguished from the other inhabitants
by the honorable title of the unn stripe
due to their industrious nature and
their tiny spaces that they came to
called home in 2010 the government
actually passed a measure which declared
the underground community illegal which
is just lovely considering that
government work is why many of the
migrants are there in the first place
the government cited our desire to
reclaim the old air-raid shelters and
refurbished them for public use Oh
a hundred thousand people were evicted
from the underground in 2015 no previous
efforts to close down the makeshift
housing in hostels of the rat tribe were
met with unprecedented public protests
for now the long-term prospects for the
community are in jeopardy but as long as
they aren't forcibly removed from the
premises the rat tribe will continue to
make the most of their simple yet cozy
accommodations deep within the untamed
Outback of Australia lies the town of
Coober Pedy after the 1915 discovery of
opal gemstone just waiting to be plucked
from the arid soil the town sprang up
almost overnight the sirens song of
precious gems brought people from all
around the world to try their hand at
mining what's they soon realized just
why the Outback is so notorious
sweltering temperatures assailed the
fresh-faced miners during the summer
whilst a winter saw temperatures plunged
dramatically in mockery of the former
heat undaunted by the perilous
environment the miners put their heads
together to come up with a novel
solution that solution of course was to
move the mining town underground though
nobody cares to admit it I do suspect
some manner of venomous creatures also
had a hand in prompting relocation
efforts it is Australia after all old
mine shafts and new holes carved into
the sandstone became homes for the
inhabitants of Coober Pedy
especially in the early years most of
the digging wisdom by hand though since
then their task has been delegated to
machinery better suited to the word as
the 20th century rolled on homes grew
more complex some growing into hotels
and inns to manage the influx of
tourists coming to bear witness to this
peculiar town modern coober pedy homes
include all of the expected amenities
like fully featured kitchens and walk-in
closets
besides housing some dugouts became
stores museums and a church as well
spending any amount of time in the
unrelenting heat of the Australian
outback is bound to prompt prayers of a
cool summer from even the least
religious person today
tourism rivals the opal as the
foundation upon which kuba P DS economy
lies
if you happen to find yourself in the
area be sure to stop by the underground
motel a rare opportunity to experience
the wonders of living beneath the earth
without committing wholeheartedly to the
lifestyle if you like it who knows maybe
there's a dog out with your name on it
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
[Music]
you